riding a wave is like suddenly gaining
speed and gliding at the same time like
walking on water like flying I think
it's really about being one with a
natural phenomenon a surfboard requires
a lot of economic thinking how do I
stand on it how do I not slip off but at
the same time it really has to work in
that fluid environment it's really
considered for the writer in some areas
and/or water in physics and others
surfboarding is made out of a core
element which tends to be foam which
makes the board float and the skin of
the board is some kind of resin epoxy
sometimes fiberglass there often is also
a stringer of wood piece down the middle
which makes it stronger the rocker is
the curvature of the board in the front
that is important because that
determines what kind of wave you will be
able to take how steep the wave is the
tail affects performance different tails
will make the board react differently so
it's a lot about personal preference our
understanding or surfing comes from when
the Tahitians and 1200 ad brought it to
Hawaii so when James Cook arrived around
1780 he was mesmerised by hundreds of
people in the water children and women
men surfing naked Calvinist missionaries
arrived and they're scandalized but it
becomes an illegal activity it becomes
counterculture father of modern surfing
is a Hawaiian name Duke Kahanamoku he is
an extraordinary swimmer when gold at
the Olympics in 1912 goes around the
world to show his swimming but brings
surfboards and demonstrates surfing
imagine people had never seen surfing
before suddenly some person from a
faraway place is standing on water
riding on water he comes back to Hawaii
and they start to make more boards pre
Second World War
you're still looking at the
heavy wood board post Second World War
new materials and new technologies
become available and those make the
board lighter more accessible cheaper
but it continues to be a custom object
something that is made specifically for
a person or for a CERN spa it's a very
symbiotic relationship between surfer
and shaper there's so many different
criteria that affect the physics of how
that surfboard is moving in water
longboard is typically used on smaller
waves the writing has a lot of style and
walk the board but you toes over it do a
hang ten a short board will be faster
they're harder to ride they sink under
the body board design comes at the
intersection between those physical
factors and really how I want to put
myself in the water it's an expression
as much as it is physical activity the
draw maybe because water is so elusive
you can't fight it you can't change it
the best I can do is recognize what it
does the surf may be big and getting
bigger and surging while you in the
water the elements are changing the wind
is coming up you have to be in symbiosis
with the environment you need to look
and feel for everything that's happening
around you and yet it's so short five a
15 seconds it's fleeting but you have to
go back to it